et depuis samedi l'inquiétude était vive
concernant l'île de groix en face de
lorient cette île peuplée en hiver n'a
pu être secouru que ce matin et le bilan
est encore plus lourd que ce que l'on
craignait
sur place les habitants sont désespérés
et se demandent s'ils retrouveront un
jour un littoral propres reste inopérant
qui s'abat seul complètement seul sur
cette plage face à l'étendue des dégâts
depuis vendredi cette île en face de
lorient subi de plein fouet l'arrivée
des nappes de pétrole lettre du
continent n'a pu se déployer rapidement
en raison de la tempête alors contre
vents et marées les groisillons n'ont
donc pu que prendre leur courage à deux
mains pour lutter contre ce poison plur
le goût est mon bien scoléo au mazout et
c'est pratiquement impossible à enlever
la preuve regardez ces sévices q comme
tout ça part en gros paquet et le pire
c'est qu'à chaque marée ce sera comme ça
voilà les nappes ont pris tout le monde
de court pas de dispositif prêt sur
place la menace était pourtant la tente
car groix est la première terre à l'est
de l'épave de l'erika les insulaires
sont consternés pour bien consomme
moteur l'eau du bain commune notre île
si on ne fait pas ça à personne fente
céder à son en renfort 70 pompiers sont
arrivés sur l'île mais c'est maintenant
le matériel qui manque et le stockage
qui fait des fous le sable souliers
entassés sur les plages repart à la mère
débordée aussi cette fois sur le
continent le centre de secours des
oiseaux montée en catastrophe avec sa
chaîne de bénévoles saturation ce n'est
plus qu'un centre de transit pour trier
les oiseaux et les évacuer au plus vite
vers la belgique où l'angleterre
personne n'imaginait une telle hécatombe
des oiseaux de mer des oiseaux vivant
sur la côte qui s'effondre
les cartons s'entassent et le nombre des
victimes dépasse déjà largement celui
des autres marée noire en france